بغمزه وتاكيد على مسيره ومستقبل سيكون
باهرا لميسي هنا الرئيس الامريكي جوبا
ايضا نجم المنتخب الارجنتيني بعد ضفره
بكاس العالم بعدين الذي عبر عن اعجابه
بميسي اكد قائلا على حسابه في تويتر اعتقد
ان ميسي قد يكون له مستقبل هذه تغريده
اثارت الكثير من السخريه من قبل رواد ما
وقع التواصل الاجتماعي خصوصا ان بعيدا
يتحدث عن مسيره ميسي التي قاربت على
النهايه وعلق احد المغردين لقد كان لديه
بالفعل مستقبل من الواضح انك من محبي
السكر وليس كره القدم في اشاره منه الى
تسميه الامريكيين كره القدم بسكر
[موسيقى]
لانه دائما في خلاف تاريخي بين
البريطانيين والامريكان لعبه الشعبيه لدى
الامريكيين بيقولوا لها سوكر اما
البريطانيين فوتبول فوتبول يعني حتى من
الاول كمان كان في فيديو شهير لبايدر عم
بيوجه لهم رساله تكون صقر